groupe que vous présidez comprend
aujourd'hui plusieurs autres chaînes
hertziennes comme gulli w9 et sister des
chaînes payantes sur les réseaux des
opérateurs de communications mais aussi
des radios comme rtl rtl2 et fun radio
votre groupe est également un des
actionnaires de la plateforme salto créé
avec france télévisions et tf1
votre parcours et votre expérience font
de vous un des meilleurs connaisseurs de
l'évolution du secteur des médias ne
seront donc heureux de partager
nous sommes donc heureux de partager
avec vous ce matin vos analyses sur les
évolutions nécessaires pour permettre
aux acteurs historiques de résister à la
concurrence des grandes plateformes
américaines alors que le gouvernement
s'apprête à transmettre au parlement et
même au sénat en premier lieu de
normalement je la parenthèse pour mes
collègues le texte sera présenté au
conseil des ministres demain un projet
de loi consacré essentiellement au
rapprochement du csa et de l'hadopi
vous nous direz s'il est raisonnable de
reporter encore une fois à plus tard une
réforme ambitieuse de la loi du 30
septembre 1986 cette loi a certes permis
de développer un secteur dynamique de la
production mais elle a aussi limiter les
droits d'exploitation de ses oeuvres
dont bénéficient les éditeurs cette
situation est-elle encore tenable
quand des plateformes comme netflix
obtiennent des producteurs français des
conditions beaucoup plus favorables qui
leur permettent de conserver des les
droits des programmes qu'il finance
comment plus généralement rétablir
l'équité entre les acteurs historiques
et les nouveaux acteurs je ne serait pas
complet si j'oubliais d'évoquer l'avenir
de votre groupe depuis que votre
actionnaire principal le groupe allemand
bertelsmann annoncé son intention de se
retirer du marché français la possible
vente du groupe m6 et rtl constituerait
évidemment un changement structurel qui
posent des questions en termes de
maintien de la diversité des programmes
de concentration des acteurs et de
formation d'un géant sur le marché de la
publicité
comment faut-il analyser l'annnonce de
votre actionnaire
la réglementation française
empêche-t-elle l'émergence de leaders
locaux que les dirigeants de bertelsmann
appelle pourtant de leurs voeux
est ce que le législateur doit selon
vous envisagez des évolutions pour
permettre l'émergence de grands groupes
de médias français de taille européenne
tout autant autant de questions bien sûr
qui nous préoccupe et sur lequel je sais
vous avez une réflexion approfondie pour
évoquer tous ces sujets je vous propose
maintenant vous devez vous céder la
parole pour 10 à 15 minutes avant de
laisser notre rapporteur pour avis sur
les crédits de l'audiovisuel il sera
également rapporteur du futur projet de
loi
jean raymond ligonnet vous posez une
première série de questions j'ajoute que
cette audition fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo et d'une diffusion sur
le site du sénat
c'est le président je vous laisse le
micro
votre invitation mesdames et messieurs
merci nous donner l'occasion comme
souvent au sénat de pouvoir expliquer
les enjeux de notre secteur et des
questions auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés de manière récurrente
en ce qui concerne le secteur actuel et
il est il est bouleversé depuis un
certain nombre d'années
si vous bien pour la clarté les choses
je vous fais un tout petit historique
et puis ensuite peut-être développer les
quelques questions qui se posent à nous
aujourd'hui et qui sont évidemment tout
à fait importante pour l'avenir de notre
métier et de notre secteur
lorsque nous avons créé cette société en
issu de la loi du visuel il y avait déjà
un problème de compétition et de marché
puisque dans la télévision analogique
dans les années 87 nous avons connu la
première faillite puisque le 13 avril 92
s'est arrêté la cinquième chaîne de
télévision et l on parlait déjà de
chaînes en trop dans le marché c'est à
dire que la loi puis la régulation a
instauré une compétition qui a été
fatale à l'un des acteurs français
ensuite dans les années 2000 le digital
a commencé à faire son apparition nous
avons créé tps avec nos collègues nous
n'avons pas pu continuer tps dans une
compétition qui était trop importante
avec le groupe canal+ alors leader sur
le marché notamment avec les droits
principalement du cinéma et de football
ça a été une course très violente très
importante très forte et la france
n'avaient pas le moyen d'avoir deux
opérateurs de télévision payante
puissant sur le territoire français
ensuite dans les années 2005
c'est elle et après après les décisions
de 2002 la tnt est arrivé et là notre
position était mal comprise puisque nous
avons avec notre collègue de tf1 nous
avons n'ont pas amené des réserves sur
la technologie de la tnt bien au
contraire nous avons simplement mis des
réserves la façon dont elle avait été
organisée en france
souvenez-vous n'ayant pas tiré les
enseignements précédent d'un excès
concurrentiel
la tnt s'est ouverte avec des facteurs
de diversité des opérateurs pluralisme
et nous avons créé tout un tas de chênes
enfin le régulateur a autorisé d'abord
en 2005 puis en 2012 tout un tas de
chaîne mais surtout c'était pas le
problème de la diversité des chaînes qui
a été un sujet ses pointes de la
diversité des opérateurs
il y avait trop d'opérateurs sur le
marché il y a trop d'opérateurs sur le
marché en france ce qui a amené des des
attributions qu'on est et qui n'ont pas
été suivies de création c'est j'ose dire
il même des abus qui ont été dénoncés
par vous même et il ya eu d'ailleurs des
amendements de circonstance dont nous
sommes actuellement victime j'en citerai
un l'amendement azoulay qui a été
apportée alouettes du visuel ce vus
l'excès de certains d'achat revente de
fréquences attribuées il ya eu une
interdiction pour les opérateurs de
revendre une nouvelle autorisation
pendant les cinq ans qui suivent
l'attribution cette autorisation il se
trouve que notre société et nos
actionnaires notre action de contrôle
qui est là depuis 34 ans qui a fait son
travail qui a été de manière secure a
accompagné le développement investit
près ces risques et cetera après le 5
mai 2022 2023
s'il venait à rester comme actionnaire
de contrôle seraient entre guillemets
parlez moi l'expression coincé jusqu'au
5 mai 2028
parce que nouvelles autorisations 23 il
ne pourrait pas revendre la société où
le contrôle plutôt de la société qui l'a
accompagné pendant 34 ans je rappelle
que notre société a été créée par deux
actionnaires l'un français l'autre
européen un français c'était la
lyonnaise des eaux pour les raisons qui
lui appartiennent
elle a cédé sa participation dans les
années 2000 il n'y avait pas de
jurisprudence azoulay le poc et ensuite
le groupe rtl vous avez fait référence
le président et rester l'actionnaire de
contrôle de la société il a fait son
travail de manière il continue de faire
son travail de manière correcte pour des
raisons je pourrais vous expliciter
il a souhaité examiner les conditions
d'un éventuel retrait du marché
encore une fois je dirais que ta doc
seulement l'amendement azoulay a pour
objectif d'accélérer plus tôt sa forte
plutôt que c'est une sortie
éventuellement organisé puisque après le
2023 donc la loi n'ayant pas été modifié
sur ce point des opérateurs et des
actionnaires historiques comme les
nôtres ne ne pourrait pas se retirer
pendant les cinq années suivant la
nouvelle autorisation il en est de même
d'ailleurs des actionnaires des autres
chaînes lorsqu'elle se seront renouvelés
donc on a totalement rigidifier sur ce
point là le marché le marché français
alors je reviens à l'instant sur la tnt
parce que c'est très important donc la
tnt à créer une nouvelle chaîne
incontestablement intéressante pour
certaines d'entre elles assez peu
d'ailleurs dans les nouvelles surtout
sur le plan de la création mais a
surtout créé de multiples opérateurs qui
ont pour fonction un excellent
concurrentiel qui aujourd'hui a rendu
les acteurs locaux c'est à dire les
acteurs français en position plus
vulnérable lorsque nous avions défendu
notre position avec nos collègues de tf1
notamment à l'époque nous souhaitions
que les opérateurs installés sur ce
marché soit les gages de la diversité il
y avait déjà une forte concurrence en
en 2005 quand les chaînes se sentent tnt
se sont développées et cette concurrence
entre des grands opérateurs auraient été
plutôt créatrice de valeur plutôt que de
multiplier le nombre d'opérateurs qui
ont une cesse ensuite de revendre leurs
chaînes souvent avec des fortes plus
values et qui n'a entraîné aucun intérêt
dans la création et dans le
développement culturel
nous en sommes là nous en sommes là
aujourd'hui avec simplement une
transition encore plus importante et
plus bouleversantes qui sont l'arrivée
des plateformes que le troisième temps
de la révolution audiovisuelle et
l'arrivée des plateformes cette fois ci
ne fait plus une concurrence entre les
acteurs locaux
où les acteurs européens mais c'est une
concurrence évidemment internationale
avec les moyens internet qui contourne
ce qui était la protection de la loi
c'est-à-dire la tnt
enfin les fréquences avais je rappelle
la règle des 20 % d'extra communautaire
et c'est aujourd'hui une concentration
de la protection entre guillemets sur la
tnt et il y a une assez grande liberté
sur le reste c'est à dire les smad en
france en tous les cas sur les smad
internationaux qui ont profité d'une
réglementation très souple pour
s'installer comme dans d'autres pays sur
le territoire français ces acteurs
mondiaux n'ont plus aucun correspondance
avec notre activité en termes de taille
en termes de puissance en terme de
capitalisation ils sont parfois 100 x
200 fois plus important que nous en
terme de capitalisation de chiffre
d'affaires de résultats je vous en un
seul exemple nous avons nous estimons
que fx investi à peu près un milliard de
dollars par an dans la technologie
simplement dans la technologie
m6 nous notre groupe investissait 17
millions dans le streaming
donc nous avons décidé de regrouper les
acteurs européens dans une société de
streaming qui s'appelle bedrock et cette
société de streaming fait le streaming
des des hollandais et des luxembourgeois
des croates des hongrois des français
bien sûr exalto et m6 et nous allons la
développer pour avoir un streaming
c'est une technologie cette belle
installé entre lyon et paris pour
développer nous espérons avoir 600 700
collaborateurs assez rapidement en ayant
de nouveaux clients mais ça nous n'avons
pas de difficultés sur le plan technique
les difficultés ils viennent sur le plan
des contenus
donc là je le la difficulté pour la tnt
c'est qu'elles concentrent toutes ses
obligations
même si le décret smad va introduire
quelques obligations sociétés
internationales ce décret ce mal est
encore très déséquilibré par un poids
notre activité et nous y reviendrons tu
es sur la production
nous avons de graves soucis en matière
de production alors quel est le moyen de
résister à cette nouvelle concurrence
puisque c'est sa l'objet 1
est-ce que c'est utile faut-il défendre
les acteurs historiques français et 2
qu'elles sont si la réponse est oui
quels en sont les moyens et les éléments
qui pourraient être mises en place
est-ce que c'est utile nous pensons que
les acteurs français locaux sont les
seuls à pouvoir résister à
l'envahissement des plateformes
c'est utile sur le plan de l'information
nous l'avons vu par rapport aux réseaux
sociaux nous avons des rédactions nous
avons des journalistes ceci coûte de
l'argent que ce soit en radio en
télévision
mais ceci donne une responsabilité
éditoriale et donc nous pensons que sur
le plan de la démocratie il est utile
d'avoir des acteurs historiques qui
peuvent faire leur métier et qui peuvent
avoir une responsabilité éditoriale dans
le traitement de l'information
je pense que pas besoin d'expliciter
plus avant sur ce point deuxièmement sur
le plan de la production et de la
création
est ce utile puisque maintenant les
acteurs type mais six vont produire et
voir exporté dans le monde entier des
programmes français
la réponse est oui selon moi parce que
aujourd'hui vous êtes soit locale c'est
nationale soit internationale
c'est très difficile d'être entre les
deux et pour être international nous
n'avons pas les moyens nous n'avons
jamais eu les moyens des acteurs
français d'être international ya les
grands studios américains
demain les en studio comme disney fox
était terrain de grandes mains des
grands studios chinois ont une capacité
que nous n'avons pas où nous n'avons
plus depuis de très très très nombreuses
années donc ces studios qui ont souvent
ceux qui ont créé les plateformes type
disney ont une puissance de feu
considérable
est-ce donc est ce fini la compétition
et faut-il rendre les armes
il nous semble que non pour plusieurs
raisons la première raison c'est que les
décisions de création ne peuvent pas se
prendre tout sur la côte ouest
américaine ou sur le sud de la chine
car demain si nous sommes un des pays
l'audiovisuel français représente à peu
près entre 7 et 8% l'audiovisuel
mondiale nous serons
traiter à 7 ou 8% dans les décisions
d'investissement de ça et il y aura un
rapport de force qui ne pourra plus
inversée il est déjà difficile
il ne pourra plus à verser nous aurons
plus qu'à constater ça sera horriblement
difficile de sanctionner plate forme par
exemple dans la mesure où couper l'accès
à ce qui constituerait l'essentiel de
l'audiovisuel français par à travers ces
plateformes sera quasiment impossible
donc nous avons intérêt à voir des
contrepoids c'est contrepoids
c'est nous les acteurs historiques les
acteurs historiques et pour ce faire
nous avons besoin d'un effet de taille
et nous avons besoin d'un effet de
concentration verticale et horizontale
verticale
ceux ci se développe dans tous les pays
france de dpi mondiaux et nous avons la
particularité d'avoir voulu par un
esprit masochiste incroyable interdire
la concentration verticale c'est à dire
l'intégration de la production est une
sanction en france c'est un
encouragement chez tous mes collègues
européens et mondiaux
et ça j'y reviendrai si vous voulez
c'est un point absolument fondamental
nous avons nous nous produisons une
vingtaine de films par an nous le
faisons en dehors de nos obligations et
nous sommes très souvent pénalisés
lorsque nous le faisons que ce soit par
la distribution des aides du cnc
que ce soit par la comptabilisation dans
nos engagements du cinéma sur les
mandats sur la façon d'approvisionner
nos antennes et cetera j'y reviendrai je
donnerai un seul exemple lorsque vous
voyez que les plateformes pourront faire
leurs obligations avec des achats de
catalogue de films français
ces achats de catalogue de films
français le conseil d'état d'ailleurs
vient de proposer de rejeter la
disposition qui interdirait
l'exportation des catalogues donc la
voie est ouverte pour acheter les grands
catalogues du cinéma français
ça rentre dans les obligations lorsque
nous nous le faisons ce que nous
achetons les catalogues nous développons
des droits ce n'est pas dans nos
obligations
ce jeu donne ce seul exemple pour vous
montrer que l'intégration verte et aime
notre métier c'est de développer les
activités de production et pas
simplement de diffusion ses activités
production du le faisons avec des
créateurs
faisons pas tout seul nous avons des
contrats de longue durée avec les
créateurs rémunérer les auteurs dont il
ne s'agit pas de faire tout nous mêmes
mais comme le font les grands studios
dans le monde nous avons des accords
pour développer des films et nous
produisons des films dont nous prenons
l'intégralité du risque
les astérix par exemple nous produisons
des astérix on dépend des dizaines de
millions pour ça et nous en prenons le
risque et nous faisons nous estimons
faire notre métier et si nous ne le
faisons pas ces les plateformes qu'ils
feront demain et c'est plate forme le
fond dans des conditions infiniment plus
difficile pour la france que nous ne
faisons nous aujourd'hui donc je
reviendrai si vous voulez bien sur
l'intégration verticale en répondre à
vos questions si vous le souhaitez parce
que pour moi c'est un point absolument
fondamental il ne s'agit pas de renier
l'intérêt de la production indépendante
il s'agit simplement de rétablir un
équilibre pour me permettre et inciter
les opérateurs historiques que nous
sommes à se développer et investir dans
les séries dans les films et dans les
programmes de flux également et nous
avons nous développer un écosystème pour
ça mais nous sommes freinés
car la comptabilisation de ceux ci dans
nos obligations de production et est
complexe et je reviendrai il y en a une
occasion historique parce que je reviens
à l'instant là dessus les producteurs
qui sont censés être protégés dans la
production indépendante maintenant ce
sont généralement des très grands
groupes
kkr et cetera ce sont des très grands
groupes qui sous l'abri de quelques
personnalités physiques tout à fait
intéressante on tienne en réalité la
production aujourd'hui la filiale
d'eyetv est plus protégé que la filiale
de m6 nous paraît quand même un peu
abusif et et profitons du fait que les
producteurs vont avoir des commandes
importantes et continuerons à voir des
commandes importantes des plateformes
pour rééquilibrer non pas pour ne plus
travailler j'ai producteurs indépendants
mais comme l'avait suggéré un ministre
il ya maintenant quelques années
deux ou trois ans de rétablir un critère
sont modifier les règles telles qu'elles
sont aujourd'hui simplement le curseur
qui nous permet de fait entre 15 et 20%
de production simplement dépendantes ce
curseur pourrait être prolongé le
ministre avait parlé de 50% nous sommes
ouverts même à un taux qui soit un peu
différent simplement ce que je veux dire
ne nous demandons pas de négocier après
des rapports et des rapports et des
rapports avec les organisations
professionnelles qui bénéficie pardon
pour certaines d'entre elles d'une rente
sous prétexte de protéger le petit
producteur c'est pas le petit
documentariste bon et qui n'aboutira à
rien dans la négociation à rien il faut
que les pouvoirs publics prennent leurs
responsabilités s'ils veulent défendre
l'audiovisuel français il faut rétablir
un curseur qui fasse que il n'y est pas
ceci cela je vous donne un exemple parce
que je pense que quand on parle
concrètement on comprend mieux les
choses
nous avons développé avec en repérant
sur l'europe un concept que vous voyez
que certains peut voir tous les soirs et
qui est un succès qu'est le premier
succès de fiction française en france
quotidien ces scènes de ménages
bon ceci c'est notre plus gros succès
c'est le plus gros succès du producteur
avec lequel nous travaillons qui
d'ailleurs a très très bien travaillé et
grâce à ce travail à développer sa
société
tout va bien il ya plus de 4 millions de
français qui regardent tous les soirs
tous les soirs ça fait travailler un
nombre incalculable hauteur de comédien
de réalisateur
ceci ne rentre pas dans nos obligations
de production ça ne rentre pas nos
obligations truzion pourquoi ce que nous
protégeons nos droits avec le producteur
parce que nous ne voulons pas évidemment
pas que cette série revienne sur une
chaîne concurrente capteront 42 mois
plus tard et donc nous avons un contrat
de longue durée
fort bien rémunéré d'ailleurs pour le
producteur quelques talentueux et tout
va bien tout va bien mais pourquoi cet
interdit de développer ça et donc nous
sommes limités puisque 80 % à 85 % du
reste nous devons le faire dans des
conditions différentes où nous rendons
les droits de 42 mois je dis souvent
nous payons le prix du propriétaire pour
être simplement locataires
donc je referme la parenthèse pardon
d'avoir été un peu long sur la
production parce que c'était pour nous
un aspect fondamental dans on parle
souvent de concentration horizontale
je pense qu'il est très important que
les sociétés produits et les sociétés de
diffusion comme dans tous les pays
notamment nord-américain s'équipent pour
produire et produire les créateurs quand
vous prenez disney disney c'est
l'exemple même il fait du streaming et
ce n'est plus il fait de la production
il a de plein de chaînes de télévision
et ils développent évidemment son
activité studio nous souhaiterions faire
la chose en europe vous avez eyetv eyetv
studio et vous avez les chaînes de mtv
et ya aucune limitation d'aucune sorte
pour le développement de ceux ci 2e 2e
remède éventuellement par rapport à
cette confiance violente fondamentale
très forte c'est la concentration dans
la concentration nous l'avons fait ces
jeux dire sans le dire ou en le disant
mais sans ça ce voit fondamentalement
quand nous faisons tps nous mettons
autour de la table d'abord range à
l'époque le service public tf1 m6 nous
avons fait nous avons duré dix ans de
porter ps et puis finalement nous avons
recéder à canal+ cette participation
dans un esprit de concentration parce
que canal+ à l'époque avait besoin de se
concentrer
lorsque nous faisons salto salto nous
n'avons pas les moyens de lutter de
manière efficace contre netflix ou
contre disney ou contre amazon très
violent comme comaga nous disons plutôt
que de rester tout seul dans notre coin
nous sommes les premiers à faire ce en
europe
nous allons voir nos concurrents et nos
collègues tf1 nos concurrents et nos
collègues du service public dans est ce
qu'il n'est pas plus intelligent
d'essayer de faire quelque chose qui à
base de programmes français d'abord
puisse lutter efficacement contre ça les
complexités
et que nous comprenons que l'autorité de
concurrence a mis dans la définition
actuelle des marchés sont sont d'une
sonde une rigueur que vous n'imaginez
pas complexité que n'a absolument pas
disney quand il se marie avec fox et qui
nous fait disney plus et puis ensuite un
deuxième service que vous avez a vu
arriver et donc cette complexité de
fonctionnement si je pouvais vous la
décrire en détail vous vous apercevrez
que on fait tout pour que ça marche pas
voilà donc on est obligé de faire deux
fois plus d'efforts voire trois fois
plus d'efforts pour arriver à ce que ça
le tour soit un succès alors les
français ont il faut s'en prendre un peu
aussi à nous mêmes parce qu'on sait des
procès entre nous sans arrêt et donc
l'autorité de concurrence est obligés de
veiller à l'équilibré de tout ceci
mais je n'ai pas le droit par exemple de
savoir ce qu hachette salto en permet de
détailler donc en étant actionnaire à 33
% je n'ai pas le droit de nous avons été
obligé de démissionner que mes collègues
du conseil de salto pour laisser
maintenant salto puisque il y à un
mandataire à chaque fois que nous nous
réunissions donc dans les règles
actuelles de compétition c'était pas une
critique contre l'autorité de
concurrence mais dans les règles
actuelles de compétition ce qui montre
bien qu'il faut les bouger faire une
initiative commune comme nous l'avons
fait avec salto est un parcours du
combattant
donc les règles de deux les règles de
concurrence
aujourd'hui nous sommes les uns et les
autres trop petit pas ce puissant pour
résister à au plate forme qui opèrent en
france et donc la concentration
verticale doit s'accompagner de
possibilités de concentration
horizontale à la fois dans le dispositif
anti-concentration limitation du nombre
de chaînes limitation du nombre de
médias détenus
aujourd'hui nous nous intégrons des
médias nous avons acheté la radio en
octobre 2010 est parce que nous estimons
que l'un et l'autre s'enrichissent vous
le voyez tous les jours sur nos antennes
entre rtl et m6 nous nous enrichissons
habituellement et donc ce ce multi média
être important évidemment dans le
digital
nous ne sommes pas restés inactifs nous
avons été les premiers à sortir en 2008
le riz
play aujourd'hui nous avons une
plateforme d2a vote très importante où
il ya à peu près un million quatre cent
millions cinq cent mille français qui
viennent tous les jours sur la
plateforme six plaies voir des
programmes soient nouveaux soient
anciens sur notre plateforme
financé par la publicité donc nous
développons ses activités mais nous
avons quand même besoin de regroupement
pour éviter une compétition acharnée qui
face à des plates formes extrêmement
extrêmement riche
on a évidemment des difficultés alors
enfin dernier point la tnt la tnt mérite
d'être défendu la tnt elle a plusieurs
avantages elle est quasi universelle
nous avons pris un engagement de
couverture qui nous coûtent très cher
97% des territoires sont couverts par la
tnt
elle est gratuite la tnt vous pouvez
offrir un service totalement gratuit
vous n'êtes pas obligé de payer un
abonnement de boxe la tnt
elle peut être technologique elle peut
faire de l'uhd la norme hbbtv couplé
avec internet permet des services
interactifs de la publicité ciblée des
interventions du téléspectateur et ses
parents et la tnt est écologique puisque
une étude de la bbc montre que 1 1-1
téléspectateurs qui regardent la
télévision via la tnt consomment deux
fois et demie moins de d'énergie que
lorsqu'il ne consomme par les boks à
cause des serveurs à cause de 2 de la
consommation électrique des instruments
qui sont mis dans le streaming est donc
ce sont des atouts importants et
pourtant la tnt supporter toutes les
obligations support toutes les
obligations la production vient d'en
parler mais il ya de multiples
obligations qu'elle le qu'elle supporte
certaines sont totalement légitime sur
le l'audiodescription etc
mais seule la tnt supporter ses
obligations les autres services n'ont
pas les mêmes obligations
et donc si on veut maintenir la tnt
il faut assouplir le cadre de
fonctionnement de la tnt et lui rendent
plus équitable par rapport aux autres
modes de distribution
alors comment le rendre plus équitable
d'abord pour faire des investissements
technologiques il nous faut de la
visibilité nous sommes renouvela tout
comme tf1 le 5 mai 2023 nous devons
recevoir une nouvelle autorisation dans
une procédure très lourde très complexe
que mènera le csa nous n'avons pas de
visibilité aujourd'hui au delà du 5 mai
2023 et donc 6 en l'absence de
visibilité il édifie il est difficile de
s'engager sur le hdd est difficile de
s'engager sur des programmes
d'investissement très important de
couverture
je rappelle que la couverture à 97%
l'inconvénient de la tnt pour nous c'est
que c'est nous qui payons la diffusion
voilà mais nous sommes prêts à le faire
si on nous donne un cadre qui soit plus
souple par rapport à ça enfin la tnt
elle lieu
elle nécessite aussi qu' il ya une
certaine souplesse
aujourd'hui si vous êtes propriétaire
d'un service de streaming ou d'une
chaîne câble satellite ou du vous pouvez
recéder faire les mouvements
l'actionnariat que vous que vous qui
serait nécessaire ce n'est pas le cas je
voulais dit sur la tnt vous vouliez très
difficile puisque comme vous avez une
autorisation d'émettre elle est
extrêmement encadrées et souvent elle a
été tellement encadrée par les abus de
certains que nous en sommes les victimes
collatérales et donc pour toutes ces
raisons vous avez remarqué sans doute
que canal+ qui devait recevoir une
nouvelle autorisation le 31 décembre de
l'année dernière a négocié le fait de ne
pas s'engager au-delà trois ans nous
nous sommes tout à fait prêts nous
engager pour des plus longues durées
mais il ya tellement de contraintes dans
la tnt que le groupe canal+ a considéré
c'était un inconvénient d'être sur la
tnt plutôt qu'un avantage dont son son
engagement n'est que de 3 ans la tnt
elle protège aussi puisque je rappelle
que les groupes extra communautaires ne
peuvent dans des dire que 20% ce qui
n'est pas le cas des autres services
donc nous nous ceci ne nous dérange pas
nous disons simplement nous souhaitons
avoir un cadre plus souple dans lequel
nous puissions nous engager sur ce
service universel qui constitue
l'armature de aujourd'hui la télévision
française
en conclusion je suis présent je dirais
que j'aurais pu parler de la radio
également qu est-ce qui a la même
compétition par rapport au streaming
comme spotify par exemple que nos
streaming extrêmement puissant
aujourd'hui tel artiste français ne peut
pas être répétée plus de tant de fois
sur les antennes de rtl alors que sur
deezer ou sur spotify il n'y a aucune
limitation dans ce sens surtout sur
spotify donc nous avons une aiguille on
favorise si je veux m benjamin biolay
toute la journée sur rtl pas ce que je
fais une journée ça va être très
difficile compte tenu de la
comptabilisation des rotations des
quotas c'est et rien n'a bougé
absolument rien n'a bougé l'instant cela
nous sommes toujours soumis à des
réglementations extrêmement violente
dont bénéficie donc a contrario les
plateformes qui eux ne vont pas limité
si le téléspectateur l'auditeur
souhaitent écouter benjamin biolay ce
jeu l'encouragent
il le fera à un nombre de fois qu'il le
jugera nécessaire
donc je dirais que cet encadrement nous
ne demandons pas une suppression des
encadrements de l'occupation du domaine
public
nous demandons simplement qu'elle soit
adaptée à des circonstances différentes
et qui sont extrêmement violente
aujourd'hui et qui nous amène à porter
un regard très critique sur la
réglementation d'aujourd'hui qui est une
réglementation des années 80 enfin notre
actionnaire qui après 34 ans examine les
possibilités il n'a pas pris de décision
définitive de mettre fin à sa position
d'actionnaire de contrôle du groupe m6
regarde quelles sont les opportunités de
consolidation du marché français elles
sont compliquées pour les raisons j'ai
indiqué tout à l'heure aujourd'hui les
marchés pertinents ne sont plus ce
qu'ils étaient analysées et qui servait
de base de la régulation le marché
pertinent par exemple de la publicité
télévisée n'est plus le bon selon nous
le président de l'oréal déjà disait déjà
dans un article de capital il ya deux
ans que le
la publicité digitale avait bouleversé
complètement son écosystème aujourd'hui
la publicité digitale est plus
importante que la publicité télé et il
ya des phénomènes de substitution qui se
réalise tous les jours entre est ce que
j'avais ch'ti en digital le manière
ciblée ou est ce que j'avais ch'ti en
publicité télévisée et aujourd'hui comme
les les les réseaux sociaux ont une
importance telle en termes de
consommation qu'ils ont la puissance
avec les réseaux sociaux c'est ça qui
est nouveau c'est qui est la puissance
il ya le ciblage et la puissance plus le
prix puisque des organismes comme
youtube peuvent pratiquer compte tenu de
leur positionnement mondial et de leur
croissance des prix qui sont extrêmement
compétitif en contact par rapport à la
télévision ou la radio est donc
aujourd'hui analyser le marché sur le
second l'angle de la publicité
télévision ou de la publicité radio nous
paraît être un faux sang ce qui se perd
un très cher si on persiste dans cette
dans cette définition parce que cette
définition empêchent tout mouvement
important de concentration et ses
mouvements de concentration s'avère
nécessaire pas simplement en france mais
également en europe
et si pour une fois la france pour et
est en avance sur la rue défi sur les
marchés je pense qu on rendrait un grand
service à l'europe parce que beaucoup
d'autres pays sont confrontés à la même
situation
merci beaucoup pour la clarté de vos
propos et les pistes que vous avez
identifié et que bien sûr nous avons
entendu je vais passer la parole à notre
rapporteur pour une première série de
questions merci président président
merci pour un homme de médias d'avoir
préféré le présentiel à la
visioconférence et effectivement je
m'associe aux propos de laurent laffont
pour vous remercier de votre franchise
j'aurai deux types de questions qui vont
toucher à deux sujets que vous avez déjà
abordé bien sûr le programme production
et puis la tnt
ma première question portera sur
l'avenir de la plateforme tnt le sait ça
souhaite engager une expérimentation de
l'uhd d'ici 2024 qui devrait
inévitablement avoir un coût pour les
chaînes qui recourront à cette
technologie
par ailleurs la plateforme tnt ne permet
toujours pas de diffuser des programmes
enrichi
faute de pouvoir actuellement imposées
l'emploi du protocole hbbtv dans les
récepteurs de télévision
on peut rappeler également que la
détention d'une autorisation d'émettre
impose des obligations en termes
d'investissements dans la production
pour les chaînes alors que votre
autorisation d'émettre arrive à son
terme en 2023 comme vous l'avez souligné
est ce que vous croyez toujours à la tnt
quelles sont les évolutions nécessaires
à sa pérennisation
à quelles conditions un groupe comme m6
pourrait accepter de s'engager dans la
modernisation de la tnt
ma seconde question portera sur les
programmes et plus précisément sur la
réglementation de la production la
situation actuelle est marquée par la
persistance d'une très forte asymétrie
très forte asymétrie c'est un euphémisme
entre les nouveaux acteurs comme netflix
et des acteurs historiques comme vous
l'avez rappelé également comment le
législateur pourrait-il faire évoluer la
réglementation afin de préserver un
secteur de la production indépendante
dynamique et parallèlement de mieux
armer les chaînes face à leurs nouveaux
concurrents
que penseriez-vous du fait d' établir
par exemple une règle des 50 50 50 pour
cent de recours à la production
indépendante et 50% de souplesse
permettant aux chaînes de produire en
interne ou de conserver les droits
négociés de gré à gré ce qui serait la
moindre des choses
je suis président je vais vous laisser
répondre à ses premières séries de
questions qu'il y en aura d'autres par
la suite
merci beaucoup ceux de ces deux
questions importantes sur la tnt
incontestablement nous souhaitons
poursuivre sur la tnt
nous souhaitons qu'il y ait un cadre
assoupli sur la tnt
dans les perspectives de pouvoir avoir
des autorisations qui durent plus
longtemps
aujourd'hui nous devons faire vous
l'avez rappelé des investissements nuage
d et vous avez souligné l'importance
d'imposer une norme hbbtv aux
constructeurs de télévisions de
téléviseurs pour que cette norme hbbtv
donne les mêmes possibilités
d'interaction que ce qui est diffusé à
travers les box et ça c'est un arrêté il
suffit de prendre un arrêté pour obliger
les constructeurs de mettre norme hbbtv
la norme est maintenant normalisé les
normaliser en diffusion
elle doit être normalisée en réception
pour que chacun qui est un téléviseur
connecté
tous les téléviseurs qui sont vendus
sont connectables ils ne sont pas
forcément connecter ces télévisions
connectables il faut une norme pour
recevoir le signal que nous allons que
nous émettons et il n'y a pas de
normalisation c'est très important dans
l'industrie une normalisation qui lie en
europe de la norme hbbtv pour imposer
aux constructeurs notamment aux
constructeurs coréens la possibilité de
mettre une norme qui ne le feront pas
spontanément qu'ils le font dans un
rapport de force il met très volontiers
une touche netflix sur la télécommande
ils mettent moins volontairement une
norme hbbtv dans la réception des
signaux que nous en voyons donc là il
suffit procès d'un arrêté c'est tout à
fait je dirais que c'est de la
protection nationale mais tout à fait
ouverte puisque c'est s'est normalisée
donc pour les raisons j'avais indiqué
tout à l'heure la l'universalité et
enfin nous ne souhaitons pas non plus
dépendre totalement deshayes failli les
faits ils ont leur logique qu'ils ont
des logiques commerciales c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons des
discussions commerciales pour distribuer
nos signaux puisqu'ils font payer le
téléspectateur le consommateur donc nous
avons des discussions dont qui sont
parfois un peu viril sur cet aspect là
la tnt pour taux est un très bon
instrument pour que cette discussion
soit paisible
voilà
nous ne voulons pas nous retrouver
dépendant de tel ou tel opérateur dans
tel ou tel territoire et ainsi privé
comme ça a pu arriver
le téléspectateur donc c'est très
complémentaire voilà simplement nous
voudrions avoir plus de visibilité de
façon à ce que les autorisations puisse
être prolongé soit de manière
automatique soit dans des procédures
beaucoup plus souple nous n'avons pas
l'absence de 2 nous n'avons pas de
visibilité au-delà vous l'avez rappelé
du 5 mai 2023 qu'est la fin de notre
autorisation actuel nous pensons que
c'est possible sur le plan européen avec
le paquet télécom puisque nous avons des
collègues notamment en italie qu'on est
dur et d'autorisation beaucoup plus long
que les nôtres beaucoup plus longues et
donc il n'y aurait pas d'inconvénient à
ce que ces autorisations piste est
prolongée sur le plan sur le plan de la
production
les choses sont d'une simplicité totale
les producteurs les grandes sociétés de
production qui sont souvent financées
par des grands fonds se réjouissent dans
leur catalogue d'introduction du fait
qu'il ya une quasi rentrent en france
donc sous prétexte de protéger des
producteurs indépendants
on a protégé les rentes de situation de
la production
or j'ai dit qu'il était très important
en france de constituer des groupes
qu'ils puissent s'appuyer sur la
production édifiant et bizarrement vous
aurez constaté que ça l'absence de
contrainte n'a pas empêché puisque les
programmes de flux ne sont pas concernés
que manager pour ne pas nommer devienne
un leader mondial et pourtant il n'y
avait aucune réglementation pour le
faire c'est son talent sa création
aujourd'hui pourquoi il y aurait besoin
d'une réglementation très contraignantes
pour empêcher la production de fictions
nous sommes larmes au pied pour la
production de fictions et il ne s'agit
pas de le faire nous mêmes par je ne
sais quel salarié de m6 il le fait dans
un accord avec des auteurs les
scénaristes et réalisateurs des
comédiens des talents est donc
simplement nous nous souhaitons investir
mais ceci n'est pas comptabilisé dans
nos obligations de production qui sont
très lourdes
et c'est la seule chose qu'on demande il
suffirait de modifier un décret qui
déplacerait le curseur des pourcentages
qui nous sont obligés aujourd'hui vers
ces l'éden à 50% que vous avez évoqué
les dden qui avait noté un ministre
s'est même pas nous qui avions 11 il
demandé 1le dans les mêmes définitions
qu'actuellement il suffit de ne pas
changer les définitions et un décret
alors nous est dit qu entendez-vous avec
les producteurs pour que ça se fasse
mais quand vous voulez vous vous
entendre avec quelqu'un à qui vous payez
encore une fois le prix du propriétaire
et qui vous rend et et qui vous loue
l'appartement
il faudrait qu'ils soient majeau 6 pour
s'entendre avec nous et donc il convient
que les pouvoirs publics s'ils veulent
développer l'audiovisuel français et la
production est encore une fois ce n'est
pas du tout en opposition avec les
créatifs il n'y aurait pas d'un côté
parce qu'on est indépendant
au terme des mandats des obligations des
créatifs et puis de l'autre côté parce
qu'on est appuyé sur un groupe de
télévision disney fox cbs y travailler
et des talents c'est pas le directeur
financier qui est fabriqué programme
donc pour nous nous faisons des films de
cinéma et c'est avec beaucoup de talent
nous faisons même des fictions avec
beaucoup de talent ont simplement notre
investissement est limitée par la
contrainte que que vous avez relevé 50 %
oui on prend même à 40
je voulais juste aussi vous signaler que
ce problème là ne concerne pas
évidemment que les chaînes privées il
s'agit aussi d'un grand enjeu de
financement public
en effet comme vous le savez france
télévisions et le aujourd'hui un très
grand investisseur en matière de
production indépendante a conclu un
accord qu'il a revu récemment en 2019 si
j'ai pas de bêtises qui accroît
d'ailleurs encore un peu son obligation
de financement en matière de production
indépendante et donc je pense que sur
les 420 et quelques millions d'euros
qu'il investit par an dans la production
indépendante
au total une très très faible partie
lui permet d'avoir des ressources
propres sura que ça doit être moins de
1% de ses investissements production et
donc c'est un cas qui est unique en
europe
d'une part c'est intéressant aussi de
regarder ce qui se passe même en france
quand vous regarder arte qui n'est pas
soumis à cette réglementation et qui
elle peut permettre d'avoir des
productions propres de entre guillemets
de mieux rentabiliser ses
investissements
elle a des ressources propres qui vient
de ses investissements en production qui
sont plus élevés que france télévisions
alors qu'elle est de taille beaucoup
plus petite radio france aussi qui tout
fait vivre tout un tas de contenus qui
n'est pas du tout soumises à une
réglementation de ce type à des contenus
propres et donc les fait vivre à travers
ses podcasts et c'est notamment et c'est
l'avis de ses programmes en numérique et
permet au groupe d'avoir des recettes
propres et je pense qu'en matière
aujourd'hui de réflexion autour du
financement public en entend parler de
problèmes de financement public du
service public de l'audiovisuel c'est
quand même un point qu'il faut que vous
ayez en tête à queue aujourd'hui c'est
quand même essentiellement l'argent du
contribuable qui est donc réinvestis
dans des sociétés de production est ce
que l'argent du contribuable doit être
investi dans des sociétés de production
dont parlait nicolas tout à l'heure le
dernier rapport du csa sur le sujet
montrent que 40 % je crois les
investissements de france télévisions en
matière de productions indépendantes
vont vers soi média one soit newell
qu'une finale de tf1 soit encore
lagardère studio et je peux prendre une
série que vous connaissez certainement
il ya des séries qui ont été à l'origine
de france télévisions comme les hommes
de l'ombre un village français doit été
produite par la société qui s'appelle
d'être un média et qui ensuite a été
racheté en 2017 par haïti ville premier
groupe de télévision privé britannique
donc est ce que cette situation est
normale nous ne pensons qu'il faut
absolument y mettre un terme en tout cas
la modifier donc les non pas seulement
pour notre paroisse mais là aussi pour
l'ensemble du secteur
merci alors de ces deux questions je
commençais par laure darcos c'est bien
je suis de pierre antoine lévy merci
monsieur
résident j'ai beaucoup apprécié votre
dernière intervention ce que j'allais
vous poser la question sur sur également
le l'audiovisuel public et j'allais même
avoir une une petite une petite question
pleine piège si vous aviez été à la
place de delphine ernotte qu'elle était
pour vous la première des mesures qu'il
aurait fallu prendre je sens votre
frustration à tous les deux peut être
que cette loi audiovisuelle ne soit pas
uniquement aussi aussi vaste et aussi
ambitieuse qu'elle devait l'être il ya
il ya encore un an et demi deux ans moi
je voulais revenir sur deux sur deux
points
j'ai beaucoup regardé apprécié votre
politique ouvert l'environnemental je
pense que vous êtes l'est peut-être
seront les premiers en tout cas les plus
ambitieux sur ce point à l'assemblée
nationale est en train d'être discutés
la loi sur l'écologie et notamment sur
les publicités alors ça rejoint parce
que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
monsieur président sur sur la publicité
sur les changements à venir
quelle sera entre guillemets votre
stratégie aussi sur ceux sur ces sujets
là parce que c'est un sujet important
même en termes de financement j'ai un
petit regret c'est que moi j'ai vécu
enfin gg j'ai grandi avec votre chaîne
la petite chaîne qui monte et je sais
que la musique a une part moins
importante en tout cas pendant en
journée et en début de soirée sur votre
chaîne donc je trouve ça un petit peu
dommage
et puis j'aurais voulu que vous reveniez
sur sur les soeurs de gouvernance de
salto parce que j'ai subi ça aussi de
près est ce que vous dites et ça c'est
inquiétant de se dire que on avait une
ambition d'un projet intéressant
regroupant quand même les principales
chaînes et que vous ayez un mandataire
en permanence à et que vous n'ayez pas
la possibilité de pouvoir dire ce que
vous souhaitiez voilà est-ce qu'il ya
des choses à faire évoluer aussi je sais
pas si cette ce projet loi permettra
d'avoir cette ambition de pouvoir
peut-être vous aider sur sur certains de
ces points merci pierre entre les vies
bouzid merci monsieur le président
madame la secrétaire générale moi ma
question concerne
la cession du groupe m6 si vous
permettez puisqu'elle fait l'actualité
donc en avant du groupe ares le par le
président thomas sera de donc du groupe
bertelsmann fait l'actualité dans les
médias avec pas plus de six candidats
pas moins de 6 candidats qui sont se
sont manifestés donc tous les grands
groupes audiovisuels sans sur vos on va
dire vos talons et aujourd'hui c'est une
vraie fierté que vous pouvez avoir
puisque le cette réussite 33 ans après
est magnifique
par contre ça peut poser plusieurs
questions puisque le groupe qui est
pressenti c'est tf1
en tout cas celui qui pourrait avoir la
faveur de thomas sera baissée et tf1
donc si cette vente devait aboutir
quelles seraient les conséquences pour
le groupe m6 qui possède de nombreuses
chaînes sur le tnt comme le groupe tf1
des doublons sur l'été de supprimer
certaines chaînes seraient lcd à leur
tour tout cas une question que je
pourrais vous poser et de plus compte
tenu du succès de de la chaîne m6 est
notamment de certaines émissions et vous
parliez tout à l'heure de scènes de
ménages est ce que noah pas un risque de
voir le groupe tf1 il a chanté à faire
reprendre à son profit ses émissions les
plus célèbres quitte à vider la chaîne
de sa substance et de son identité si
vous voulez bien on va prendre toutes
les questions comme ça vous pourrez
répondre de manière groupée jacques
grosperrin est aussi derrière vous merci
président moi je voudrais vous féliciter
président de tout le travail que vous
avez fait l'évolution de cette chaîne
est en continuité avec la question de 40
one lévis moi aussi je suis je suis
inquiet parce que vous avez dit que les
groupes des médias européens qui étaient
plus en plus concurrencé par le
numérique doit se réorganiser
donc j'ai cru comprendre que le fait
qu'ils aient un rachat potentiel ou qui
est dans les tuyaux rouillent on le sent
bien et on entend est-ce que c'est pas
de manière aussi de pouvoir se
réorganiser aussi en interne
et c'est vrai que la première question
ça serait l'avenir de 2
de votre chaîne m6 rtl - du groupe m6
certes elle est peut-être aussi son
implantation en france
la deuxième question c'est sur le
conseil d'état qui carte doc est une
disposition du projet de loi qui visait
à instaurer un droit de regard du
gouvernement en cas de vente de
catalogues audiovisuel et c'est devenu
plus qu'un droit c'est tu devenu une
déclaration préalable à ce que c'est de
nature à vous rassurer
puis enfin une troisième question à
laquelle vous ne pouvez pas manquer
c'est ce qui s'est passé sur les dîners
mondains vous êtes au centre pas d'une
polémique parce que je pense que vous
avez fait votre travail vous êtes bien
que votre travail je pense que c'est le
rôle d'une telle vision et de médias de
parler de ce qui se passe mais
nécessairement aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas ne pas vous en parler
moi j'ai été choqué alors j'ai vu qu'il
y avait eu un communiqué la société des
journalistes de m6 qui étaient
intervenus mais j'étais choqué de
l'attitude de la personne qui a dit
qu'il n'a pas dit etc mais surtout
lorsqu'elle elle peut et où est le
prétexte le fait que c'est pour faire
tomber le gouvernement ou et les mots
qui m'ont plus surpris c'est ces mots
entre la révolution française et vichy
est-ce que vous alors ce sont des termes
qui sont outranciers est-ce que vous
réserver le droit ou de porter plainte
ou de laisser passer cela parce que pour
vous comme disait le père fort que c'est
trop excessif ça ne mérite pas de dettes
remarquer merci chez remy baki merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
président de tavernot pour votre exposé
et l'ensemble de vos éléments alors
rapidement j'avais deux trois questions
mais beaucoup de mes collègues ont aussi
dit des choses extrêmement intéressante
je partage les remarques notamment
concernant la reprise et l'inquiétude en
tout cas qui traverse un bon nombre
d'observateurs de ce qui est en train de
se passer aujourd'hui au niveau du
groupe m6 c est ce que nous arriverons
au delà de la reprise en fonction du
repreneur
conserver une certaine singularité à la
fois dans l'épreuve dans les programmes
une certaine identité si forte à la
chaîne depuis tant d'années maintenant
la deuxième question mais je m'étends
pas c'était là aussi concernant la
gouvernance de salto beaucoup
d'interrogations sur le devenir de cette
plate forme à la fois ambitieuse malgré
les difficultés que vous évoquiez en
tout cas je crois pas que son ambition
était de concurrencer les géants des
plateformes d'être tels que netflix ou
autre mais est-ce que les difficultés
que vous évoquez brièvement concernant
la gouvernance ne sont pas de nature
pour le coup parasiter le développement
de cette plateforme tant attendu par bon
nombre d'observateurs
troisième question rapidement sur les
publicités mais vous l'avez est évoquée
également comment analysez-vous les
années à venir en termes de recettes
publicitaires notamment avec la
concurrence mais ça vous en avez parlé
notamment de tout ce qui peut être en
streaming sur d'autres d'autres supports
et est ce que les entrées sur ces
nouveaux supports sont mena sur à
compenser les pertes de publicité
traditionnelle sur les chaînes du groupe
jusqu'à présent est en fait une dernière
question regard de la situation qu'on
connaît
dingue du sport des droits télé ce qui
est vrai pour le football mais pour un
certain nombre d'autres sports n'est-il
pas temps de peut-être faire évoluer le
décret léotard sur les grands événements
sportifs pour que ceux ci puissent être
retransmis en clair et quelle est votre
position évidemment là dessus et quel
impact pourrait cela pourrait avoir pour
une chaîne pour des chaînes comme les
vôtres je vous remercie monsieur le
président je voudrais laisser répondre à
cette série de questions merci beaucoup
pour tout ces questions j'ai essayé de
répondre brièvement pour et et dans
l'ordre sur la musique sur la musique
c'est justement la traduction de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui sur le digital
lorsque nous étions 87 dans les années à
30 ans la seule façon de regarder des
clips musicaux des vidéos musique
c'était d'aller sur elle
ou après w9 qui fait beaucoup de musique
également où la seule façon d'écouter de
la musique c'était de se brancher sur
rtl2 où certains de ses concurrents
aujourd'hui c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui
les clips sont donnés et ne sont
généralement pas payés par les
organismes type youtube et nous nous
devons payer l'équipe et avec souvent
une audience absolument minimes donc
nous avons discuté avec l'industrie
musicale avec le snet nous avons trouvé
un accord avec celui-ci
pour mettre en avant les nouveaux
talents parce que la musique ça marche
dans certaines conditions
c'est pas tellement la peine de diffuser
toute la journée des clips comme nous le
faisions je suis très heureux d'entendre
que vous les regardez aujourd'hui ils
sont regardées sur plein de chaînes
youtube plein et c'est de manière
gratuite
donc nous préférons nous consacrer nos
moyens mais là aussi look et des charges
ont très peu évolué lorsque nous avons
demandé de redéfinir les conventions sur
la base des autorisations qui ont été
émises dans les années 80 fait que nous
avons été attaqués sur le fait que le cs
ans qui nous avait donné les
assouplissements notamment sur w9
il ya eu une attaque contre ses
assouplissements donc on voit bien que
le système est totalement rigide
or il faudrait donner le moyen cs1 de
changer des dispositions lorsque
l'environnement change
c'était le cas de la musique de manière
flagrante sur le sport puisque pourront
reprendre les thèmes pardon les ferrain
de manière un peu disparates sur le
sport le sport sur les télévisions
commerciales
il y a engendre toujours des déficits
il n'y a pas d' équilibre lorsque nous
diffusons du sport a très peu très peu
d'exemples pour ça néanmoins d'échelle
grs comme les nôtres ont besoin de
quelques bons sport nous et nous avons
fait des efforts en étant attentif à ce
que ça soit conforme au droit de la
concurrence un très attentif pour là
aussi tenté de nous regrouper
c'est ainsi que l'euro que vous
sur nos antennes nous le partageons avec
notre collègue de tf1
nous diffusons la moitié des machos m6
la moitié sur tf1 11 chez nous je crois
est pourquoi nous l'avons fait ce pas le
plaisir de partager notre compétiteur je
pense que la réciproque est vrai aussi
c'est simplement que nous n'avons pas
les moyens de supporter le coût de
diffusion gratuitement de l'euro on
auprès de diffusion gratuite auprès
d'autres pistes d'accès gratuit auprès
de notre public donc le sport
l'élargissement des décrets des décrets
c'est une très bonne chose nous
n'aurions pas l'équipe de france sur m6
de football s'il n'y avait pas ce décret
pour les événements d'importance majeure
est donc encore une fois il appartient
aux pouvoirs publics de déterminer le
juste milieu des événements d'importance
majeure parce qu'évidemment ceci nous
protège d'avoir des exclusivités payante
sur sur sur les autres questions sur
notre notre notre actionnaire je
rappellerai simplement que cet
actionnaire a été fidèle et fidèle 34
ans 34 ans de l'accompagnement continue
et j'en profite pour répondre à l'autre
question sur les journalistes sans
intervention éditorial
je pense que c'est précieux et dans
lequel nous avons une liberté complète
et donc j'assume en tant que directeur
de publication tout ce qui a été fait et
ce qui est fait sur nos antennes sans
avoir une intervention c'est sa
politique du groupe bertelsmann rtl
group sur le contenu éditorial de nos
chaînes et ça c'est une importance je
pense que si nous avons pu développer
des magazines si nous avons développé de
l'information l'information un grand
succès actuellement sur m6 c'est parce
que nous avons une responsabilité
éditoriale qui nous a été transmise par
notre actionnaire ou laissés en tous les
cas par notre actionnaire
aujourd'hui il regarde si la
consolidation des marchés il fait la
même analyse que nous sur le marché donc
il regarde les opportunités qu'il ya
effectivement il ya ça tombe de candidat
et ça fait plaisir à nos équipes de voir
que beaucoup de candidats après lequel
viendra chez nous s'il y en a un qui
vient c'est une autre question mais en
tout
qu'at on à un moment de fierté de nos
équipes sur le travail accompli de
toutes nos chaînes et de tous nos
services audiovisuels alors il ya
beaucoup de questions examinées de
questions examinées
qu'est ce qui est compatible avec les
règles anti concentration qu'est ce qui
est compatible avec l'analyse des
marchés nous pensons cette année des
marchés devraient évoluer
il est nécessaire qu'elle évolue et
ensuite il prendra une décision non pas
pour vendre le groupe
mais pour céder tout ou partie de sa
majorité de contrôle
ceci peut se traduire par une fusion ce
qui a même conseillé sur des marchés où
peut se traduire par une vente à un
acteur déjà présents sur le marché
européen donc aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans cette analyse
enfin l'actionnaire et dans cette
analyse
la somme des contraintes évidemment l'a
surpris ou en tous les cas et dans
l'après compte la somme des contraintes
amène parfois des décisions
paradoxalement je dirais si je ne dis
pas que c'est la voie qui sera emprunté
1 mais paradoxalement la solution la
plus crainte est la plus simple c'est de
vendre ses 48 2 à 8 3% européen
circulez ya rien à voir donc ça on a eu
une réglementation qui fait que c'est le
plus simple la plus complexe c'est
évidemment avec des partenaires
industriels qui sont déjà sur le marché
et plus plus plus sont importants plus
la contrainte est lourde mais peut-être
que plus l'efficacité est grande aussi
et donc nous pensons que en tous les cas
nous avons toujours été favorable à la
consolidation et consolidation ne veut
pas dire dilution nous sommes évidemment
très attentifs et moi personnellement
j'y veillerai à ce que le travail que
nous avons fait pendant 34 ans pour
développer des marques des chaînes m6 ne
disparaîtra pas
w9 ne disparaîtra pas alors y aura
certaines sessions selon des candidats
puisque la loi maintient cette
autorisation mais c'est très variable
mais en tous les cas les marques
auxquelles nous sommes profondément
attachés ne disparaîtront pas et ça ne
sera pas l'intérêt d'un éventuel
repreneur que de les faire disparaître
le prix est ajusté c'est juste dire et
son intérêt c'est les équipes qui ont
été constitués dans le groupe m6 et les
marques qui ont été ainsi vous passez
l'expression les contenus les émissions
qui auront été mises en groupe m6
lorsque vous avez des gal m6 qui existe
depuis trente trois ans des turbos qui
existe depuis trente trois ans des
capitales depuis 20 ans c'est pas pour
les supprimer les arrêter donc c'est
simplement pour les éventuellement les
renforcer en leur donnant des moyens
supplémentaires dans une compétition de
plus en plus lourdes sur le sur le
projet de loi climat façon labellisé
valls je sais que le sénat est très
engagé aussi sur cette question sur le
donc bon ce qu'on peut dire à ce stade
c'est que le texte qui pour l'instant
plus ces deux articles qui nous concerne
de très près l'article 4 et 5 qui donc
est examiné à l'assemblée
dernièrement pour nous il s'agit d'un
équilibre qui est plutôt entre
guillemets convenable c'est j'ose dire
entre les objectifs environnementaux les
impacts économiques d'autre part donc il
ya eu comme vous savez une restriction
qui a été apportée sur la publicité pour
les promotions des énergies fossiles et
par ailleurs la mise en place d'un code
de bonne conduite
alors c'est vrai vous l'avez noté et je
vous en remercie le groupe m6 est très
et très engagé en la matière avec une
semaine green sur toutes nos antennes
qu'on a lancée bien avant d'ailleurs le
la réflexion en cours et le projet le
climat on a vu récemment encore le
documentaire legacy de yann arthus
bertrand qui a été diffusé en prime time
aussi sur m6 donc bon rapidement ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que nous on s'est
engagé pour faire un code de bonne
conduite un contrat climat avec
notamment beaucoup de deux propositions
sur plan éditorial pour continuer
d'accompagner un peu cette réflexion et
en matière écologique mais évidemment
voilà on regardera très très près tout
ce qui peut venir restreindre nikon en
parlait un peu plus les recettes
publicitaires qui sont notre seule
source de revenus avec toutes les
conséquences que l'on sait ensuite en
matière de l'information de déontologie
de l'information etc ride et de
financement des programmes donc et peu
concerné par cette fois-ci mas et là
aussi il faut faire attention de ne pas
réintroduire quel que soit l'événement
les bonnes volontés les bonnes mesures
c'est pour ça que nous avons
délibérément accepté de nous engager
sous la responsabilité du csa dans ces
accords nous avons nous faisons très
attention à cela nous avons sur quatre
car il ne rappelais sur le plan
éditorial la première émission que nous
avons commencé à faire écolo 600 1990
bon simplement un il ya un momentum
aujourd'hui pas forcément la publicité
dans la relance et la relance est aussi
de permettre de défendre l'écologie et
la deuxième chose n'accroît sont pas par
des mesures qui seraient strictement
ciblée sur les les médias contrôlés
entre guillemets nana n'ajoutons pas une
distorsion de concurrence entre le
digital d'un côté qui ne sera pas
concernée par l'essentiel de ces mesures
et les médias historiques de l'autre qui
est subir est la fois des restrictions
importantes
est ce que j'ai répondu nous les
questions qu'elle n'aimait pas répondu
je pense alors est-ce que les dîners
clandestins ou supposés comme tels
bon alors je suis pas spécialiste je
dirais simplement que moi je fais
confiance à la rédaction d'une heure 45
qui sait son travail est fait son
travail après les mises en cause par les
mises en cause donc c'est un peu
paradoxal
voilà donc je crois que la la les
journalistes ont fait un travail correct
dans lequel il a été repris ils ont été
mises en accusation par l'accusé où le
supposé comme tel je laisse chacun libre
d'apprécier comme il se doit les
informations qui ont été ont été
transmises
j'ajoute simplement que dans nos médias
nous avons un comité de déontologie qui
concerne aussi bien la radio que la
télévision le comité de déontologie se
réunit d'ailleurs il est présidé par
l'ancien sénateur de 10,6 et lorsqu'il
ya des questions qui peuvent être posées
ici ou là elles peuvent l'être
directement par le comité anthologie
j'ai pas l'impression qu'il ait lu
énormément de travail sur le groupe m6
et puis pardon j'ai alors le contrôle
des catalogues le contrôle des
catalogues je dirais que le meilleur
contrôle que les catalogues puisse
rester en france et qu'on puisse les
acheter et que ça rentre dans nos
obligations et non pas inciter les
plateformes à les acheter et les faisant
entrer dans leurs obligations
donc avant de faire un contrôle aux
frontières que jamais tout à fait
efficace
faisons en sorte que les acteurs
français historique ils ont ce marché
français puissent continuer développer
une activité de catalogue il ya des tas
de mesures pour ça et notamment de ne
pas permettre aux uns de les mettre dans
les obligations production et ne pas le
permettre aux autres déjà je pense qu on
aurait fait un bon travail et pas le
travail à l'envers ensuite est-ce que
les recettes digital
le pourront prendre la pub télé il ya un
arbitrage permanent c'est pour ça que je
conserve c'est un seul marché
il ya un souffle et vous avez plusieurs
plusieurs catégories de marchés vous
avez le marché aujourd'hui vous avez le
marché de la publicité télévision vous
avez lemercier de la publicité vidéo le
marché de la publicité display du marché
du search le marché du search il est
très particulier c'est le marché google
pour faire court il est assez
particulier et notamment il concerne
tout à part d'entreprises qui ne sont
pas concernés par la publicité
télévision preuve par contre sur le
display le marché vidéo
nous sommes en compétition nous toute la
journée avec instagram avec facebook
avec youtube ces terrains pour les
insertions publicitaires nous le serons
de plus en plus avec la publicité
segmenté que nous développons la pulse
est segmenté qui vient d'être autorisée
avec quand même une limitation la
géolocalisation l'adresse alors que dans
la publicité digitale là aussi bien
irrigué traitement on peut mettre
l'adresse mais pour nous il faut
redéfinir le marché de la télévision
dans les pays européens
nous sommes nous sommes évidemment dans
un marché qui est substituables et
aujourd'hui nous vivons cette
substitution et s'ils voulaient ce qui
est formidable c'est que vous avez des
facteurs de croissance dans la publicité
digitale qui sont phénoménaux des
quarante pour cent des 45 % le marché de
la publicité télé vision stricte est
stable depuis au mieux la dernière île à
la diminuer mais est stable depuis
depuis dix ans donc je trouve que de ne
pas nous permettre de nous regrouper
pour essayer de développer des choses et
quand même on s'apercevra dans 50 ça
serait une erreur énorme énorme il en
vint jeu je pèse mes mots
que ce soit en matière de concentration
verticale ou en matière de concentration
horizontale nous jouerons l'avenir des
acteurs historiques européens dans cette
bagarre
le problème n'est pas simplement
français sur la concentration la
définition des marchés il est européen
en ce qui concerne la production le
problème est français et paradoxalement
nous sommes en train de nous tirer une
balle dans le pied pour ne pas permettre
des investissements chez les créateurs
que les acteurs historiques sont prêts à
faire sont prêts à développer
et nous avons le même combat notamment
avec le groupe canal+ sur celle sur ce
thème là je voudrais revenir sur deux
points si vous me le permettez
concernant la tnt haute définition
nous avions compris dans les premières
discussions avec le gouvernement que
l'intention de départ était de le mettre
dans le projet de loi et on constate
dans la confirmation demain mais selon
toute vraisemblance que ça ne sera pas
dans le projet doit pas vous demandé
d'interpréter la position du
gouvernement sur ce point mais pour nous
éclairer nous dans notre réflexion et
est ce que vous pourriez nous donner des
informations complémentaires sur deux
aspects d'abord sur la haute défi de la
tnt haute définition nous préciser quels
seraient les avantages pour les
consommateurs que compris que vous y
était favorable mais pour les
consommateurs quel concrètement qu'est
ce que ça apporte
et deuxièmement on voit bien que
derrière cette question il ya aussi un
dire un conflit avec les opérateurs de
télécoms se l'utilisation des fréquences
est-ce que avancé sur la tnt hd c
limiter le nombre de fréquences qui
pourraient être libérés sur des
opérateurs et 2e série de questions sur
le la vente de m6 est ce qu'il y a un
calendrier qui est si ce n'est fixée
mais en tête et est ce que des
dispositions qui pourraient être
introduites dans le la procédure
législative qui va être engagé ici même
dans un peu plus d'un mois pourrait
avoir des incidences sur le calendrier
alors sur les fréquences vous permettait
que j'en ai eu je suis toujours très
attentif à être bienveillant avec les
télécoms qui sont des grands clients
une fois j'ai dit ça constatons
simplement que la télévision rend ces
fréquences que qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya
une nouvelle norme
les progrès que nous faisons dans la
compression permet de restituer des
bandes de fréquences de manière
régulière notamment télécom ce n'est pas
le cas des télécoms les télécoms quand
ils ont des nouvelles technologie
utilise de nouvelles bandes de
fréquences nous nous rendons nos
fréquences simplement après nous rendons
des vacances en fonction des progrès
technologiques mais pas en fonction des
restrictions des usages
donc si on devait rentrer aux deux
bandes de fréquences en 2031 virant des
restrictions d'usagé c'est-à-dire qu'il
aura plus d'universalité dont je parlais
tout à l'heure
en tous les cas d'ores et déjà il n'y a
pas de question de restitution de
fréquences aujourd'hui enfin disons dans
les dix années qui viennent et qui
permettent aujourd'hui de continuer à
développer la tnt et de bénéficier des
progrès technologiques pour faire un
multiplexe par exemple supplémentaire en
nuage des ce multiplex supplémenter en
nuage des permettra à la fois
l'équipement en récepteurs et de tester
des programmes nous le faisons également
sur le avec les opérateurs puisque nous
allons faire une chaîne ou hd pour
l'euro le prochain euro donc nous nous
avons déjà des programmes qui se
développe en hd mais si on veut ça
prenne une masse
la spark est importante comme on dit il
faut que nous ayons un multiplex qui le
développe mais ceci a un coût
ceci a un coût donc si on nous demande
de financer un multiplexe uhd sans nous
donner des perspectives que nous
puissions rester sur notre multiplex
traditionnels pour diffuser une daube
série blanc on le fera pas c'est aussi
simple que ça où on prendra pas les
engagements de couverture correspondant
voilà oui pour la tnt mais oui à
l'adaptation des procédures de la tnt
alors ne m'appartient pas de commenter
le point click je voudrais quand même
souligné que les pouvoirs publics
récemment fait à sa tombe d'efforts pour
tenter d'améliorer la réglementation sur
certains points alors qu'il y avait des
bataille d'hernani aujourd'hui on n'en
parle plus souvenez vous quand il
s'agissait de mettre des films région
interdite on nous a dit qu'on allait
ruiner cinéma français voire mondial
qu'est-ce qui nous en parle aujourd'hui
c'est comme quand on avait mis la
deuxième coupure publicitaire dans les
programmes
on nous avait dit non mais ça c'est pas
possible ça c'est sa ruine dans la
presse pourquoi personne n'en parle
lorsqu'on a introduit la publicité elle
a 10 de la distribution la télévision et
si vous regardez les mesures
d'assouplissement qui ont été prises une
fois qu'elles sont prises c'est terminé
c'est terminé c'est à dire que bien
alors là par exemple sur la publicité en
faveur du cinéma
et dieu sait si on en aura besoin pour
inciter les français à retourner dans
les salles de cinéma
nous avons même offert des campagnes
pour les pour les exploitants de salles
pendant les périodes où ces terres est
ouvert bon la publicité en faveur du
cinéma
on a tellement peur qu'on aura 17
expérimental est expérimental donc nous
vivons sous l'expérience j'ai pas
compris que c'était expérimental pour
les services digitaux du style allociné
là l'expérience dure depuis longtemps
bon donc cette prudence qui lie à
modifier la réglementation est difficile
à comprendre non ans qui connaît dès
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui
appartiennent au règlement au règlement
la régulation de la production
pas besoin de la loi enfin il ya plein
de choses qui ne peuvent fait
directement l'arrêter pour le hd tv
c'est un arrêté donc
on demande souvent parlement de prendre
des mesures qui nous incombe plutôt
réglementaire donc je dirais que de ce
point de vue là la loi du visuel les
pouvoirs publics pendant leurs
responsabilités le lait le 50/50 qui
avait été évoquée par un pasteur tout à
l'heure peut-être dans la loi pourrait
être dans la loi voilà mais ils
pourraient être aussi prise
éventuellement de manière réglementaire
on peut on peut se poser la question
soit 2 évidemment s'il y avait nous la
prolongation des autorisations pour tout
le monde pas simplement pour tel ou tel
opérateur pour l'ensemble des opérateurs
pour leur donne une visibilité que ce
soit les opérateurs tnt nouveau où que
ce soit les opérateurs historiques nous
serions nous accueillerons cette
initiative avec beaucoup de plaisir et
donc nous sommes attentifs à voir c'est
le projet de loi en ce qui concerne le
calendrier
aujourd'hui il ya un degré de complexité
extrême pour faire le bon choix
ce jeu n'étant pas propriétaire de la
majorité de contrôle du groupe m6 ne
peux pas vous dire quel sera le
calendrier exact en tous les cas je sais
que mon actionnaire de contrôle
il travaille merci je compte il n'ya
plus de questions y compris vers nos
collègues qui sont en visio merci
monsieur le président pour votre langage
très direct et les pistes que vous nous
avez identifié bien entendu fait les
avons écoutés noté avec attention
la distinction vous faisiez entre le
réglementaire et législatif ça ne nous
échappe pas parfois on s'aperçoit que
législatif permet d'avancer quand même
et d'accélérer certains aspects qui
pourraient relever du réglementaire
avait cité la nomme à la norme hbbtv
ça ne va pas qu'effectivement il suffit
d'un arrêté mais cet arrêté n'est pas
pris donc nous nous verrons là aussi ce
que nous devrons faire dans le cadre du
projet de loi mais avec avec à l'esprit
le fait qu'un certain nombre de choses
n'avancent pas alors qu'ils le
pourraient donc peut-être que le
législateur prendra sa responsabilité
pour faire avancer un certain nombre de
sujets en tout cas merci beaucoup pour
votre regard sur ce secteur de
l'audivisuel et et d'autres
connaissances à la fois des acteurs et
des voix là nous venons de vivre
ensemble l'audition devant la commission
de la culture et l'éducation du sénat de
nicolas de tavernot le président du
groupe m6 alors que faut-il en retenir
et 20 plusieurs poids important d'abord
sur le futur rachat du groupe m6 sur
lequel nicolas de tavernot n'a pas été
très bavard
nous avons toujours été favorable à la
consolidation mais consolidation ne veut
pas dire dilution m6 ne disparaîtra pas
w9 non plus a expliqué le patron du
groupe sans évoquer une seule fois son
possible racheteur tf1 il a également
évoqué les plateformes de streaming et
je vous propose qu'on l'ait coûte tout
de suite nous estimons que fx investi à
peu près un milliard de dollars par an
dans la technologie simplement dans la
technologie
m6 nous notre groupe investissait 17
millions dans le streaming
donc nous avons décidé de regrouper les
acteurs européens dans une société de
streaming qui s'appelle bedrock et cette
société de streaming fait le streaming
des des hollandais les des
luxembourgeois décroître des hongrois
des français bien sûr ex alto et m6 et
nous allons la développer pour avoir un
streaming
c'est une technologie c'est d'installer
entre lyon et paris pour développer nous
espérons avoir 600 700 collaborateurs
assez rapidement en ayant de nouveau
mais ça nous n'avons pas de difficultés
sur le plan technique les difficultés
deviennent sur le plan des contenus donc
là je le la difficulté pour la tnt c'est
qu'elle concentre toutes les obligations
même si le décret smad va introduire
quelques obligations sociétés
internationales ce décret smad est
encore très déséquilibré par un poids
notre activité et nous y reviendrons
pèsent sur la production
nous avons de graves soucis en matière
de production alors quel est le moyen de
résister à cette nouvelle concurrence
puisque c'est sa l'objet un ace que
c'est utile faut-il défendre les acteurs
historiques français et 2 qu'elles sont
si la réponse est oui
quels en sont les moyens et les éléments
qui pourraient être mises en place
est-ce que c'est utile nous pensons que
les acteurs français locaux sont les
seuls à pouvoir résister à
l'envahissement des plateformes
c'est utile sur le plan de l'information
nous l'avons vu par rapport aux réseaux
sociaux nous avons des rédactions nous
avons des gens les lisent ceci coûte de
l'argent ce soit en radio en télévision
mais ceci donne une responsabilité
éditoriale et donc nous pensons que sur
le plan de la démocratie il est utile
d'avoir des acteurs historiques qui
peuvent faire leur métier et qui peuvent
avoir une responsabilité éditoriale dans
le traitement de l'information
aujourd'hui vous êtes soit locale c'est
nationale soit internationale
c'est très difficile d'être entre les
deux et pour être international balle
nous n'avons pas les moyens nous n'avons
jamais eu les moyens des acteurs
français d'être international il ya les
grands studios américains
demain les grands studios comme disney
fox terrain de grandes mains des grands
studios chinois ont une capacité que
nous n'avons pas où nous n'avons plus
depuis de très très très nombreuses
années donc ces studios qui rend souvent
ceux qui ont créé les plateformes type
disney ont une puissance de feu
considérable
est-ce donc est ce fini la compétition
et faut-il rendre les armes
il nous semble que non pour plusieurs
raisons la première raison c'est que les
décisions de création ne peuvent pas se
prendre tout
sur la côte ouest américaine ou sur le
sud de la chine
car demain si nous sommes un des pays
l'audiovisuel français représente à peu
près entre 7 et 8% de l'audiovisuel
mondiale ben nous serons traités à 7 ou
et % dans les décisions d'investissement
de de ça et il y aura un rapport de
force qui ne pourra plus inversée il est
déjà difficile
il ne pourra plus à verser nous aurons
plus qu'à constater ça sera horriblement
difficile de sanctionner plate forme par
exemple dans la mesure où couper l'accès
à ce qui constituerait l'essentiel de de
l'audiovisuel français par à travers ces
plateformes sera quasiment impossible
[Musique]